hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from the pro Chesley
guitar versus uh Saleh Salem and yes
another talk Grandmaster has fallen
victim to the Greek gift and while the
game itself is pretty awesome I would
just like to mention one a very weird
fact that uh even though it's called the
Greek gift you don't uh sacrifice a
night and a knight is I mean interest at
night is a horse and in the Greek gift
is basically the Trojan Horse you want
to slip something nasty to your opponent
and it's interesting that a sacrifice of
the Knight on F7 or on H7 or for black
on F2 or H2 is not uh referred to as the
Greek gift in Chester minaji but in fact
it's the sacrifice of the bishop on H7
or from Black's perspective the
sacrifice of the bishop and H2 is
referred to the Greek as the Greek gift
now some say that it's merely a matter
of of mistake uh or in Translation that
it was never actually called the Greek
gift uh it was actually called the Greco
gift as jocquino Greco often played it
in his game see he very often sacrificed
the bishop on both H7 and then H2 so
maybe it's not in fact the Greek gift
and it has nothing to do with Greece or
the Greeks maybe it's just the Greco's
gift but you know who who Who's Gonna
figure that out now uh so uh we still
call it a degree gift let's check it out
how how it played out here uh it's a
match from around six of the pro chess
League the Norway gnomes versus the
levit of Chess Wizards let's see the
game
uh Pawn to E4 uh we have found the C5
solid goes for the Sicilian Defense uh
C3 uh Alexander goes for the all up in
variation Knight to F6 and now Pawn to
E5 sorry about that
uh challenging the Knight we have
knighted the D5 and now uh Knight to F3
D4 is uh still the more popular move
here but okay Knight to F3 second most
popular D6 with Bishop to B5 with check
and the bishop to D7 we have Bishop the
C4 and now E6 this is a crucial move um
uh in this position because uh you will
all if you play the album you might have
this position in your bullet games or
Blitz Games and your opponent will often
play Knight to B6 here you can check it
out in the database uh people actually
play Knight the B6 here very often or if
you play against the Petro of Defense
sometimes you're gonna attack the Knight
with Bishop to C4 they're gonna play
Knight to B6 and then Bishop captures on
F7 becomes a possibility and for those
of you who are interested this is how
you punish black and well it's possible
to defend it's so ugly that no one will
actually be able to defend this Knight
G5 check now look at this King F6 Queen
to F3 check you even offer done at the
night here and now the only defense is
Bishop to F5 if you actually capture the
knight uh then black just gets uh
checkmated very very nastily here so a
H5 checking H6 Queen E3 check you're
gonna have to block and then just Queen
captures on E6 check King to G7 and H6
will now be Checkmate this is only one
of the possible checkmates that occur if
black is not careful here but of course
the solid very strong Grand Master he
knows that he plays Spawn to E6 uh D4 we
have c cap for Sunday for and now uh in
all of the games that have reached this
position a white first played Bishop
captures on D5 but here Alexander plays
a c captures on D4 and it is now as of
move uh eight that we have a completely
new game so now Knight the B6 definitely
is an option but first we have Knights
the C6 we have castles and now Knight to
B6 challenging the bishop uh Bishop back
to B3 and now Queen to C7 we have Rook
D1 adding another Defender to the E5
Pawn uh the characters on E5 D captures
on E5 and Bishop to B4 developing with
uh with tempo as the rook and E1 is
hanging so Bishop to D2 and now solid
just castles we have knighted to C3 uh
and here uh White's position is uh
incredible here and black should be very
careful about his next move probably
something like Knight D7 Shifting the
Knight to G6 to help out with the
defense uh is the way to to go about
this position or Shifting the bishop
back with Bishop p7
but here uh solid just doesn't realize
the danger uh he's in and he plays
Knight to A5 uh he puts pressure on the
bishop here but basically wants to
re-maneuver the bishop to C4 where it
will be an excellent piece but the
problem is uh the position is now
completely lost for black and I'm sure
you guys know why feel free to pause the
video here and find the winning idea for
Alexandra while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on uh realizing
that we are making a video on the Greek
gift so we have to position our Bishop
properly and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Bishop the
C2 uh this is what Alexandra played and
now uh there is no defense against
Bishop captures on H7 it's such a such a
powerful threat that even stopping it
with the immediate G6 is not enough I'm
just gonna show you because it weakens
the dark squares too much uh if G6 then
you just uh go Knight to E4 and there's
really nothing I mean yeah it's uh a
completely winning position uh let's say
Bishop captures on D2 Queen captures or
even better first Knight to F6 check
King will move now Queen captures the
Knight here is hanging and once you move
the Knight then just a nice night stage
five-way to check uh and this game over
doesn't matter if you capture the Knight
or not the the idea is the same You're
Gonna Play Queen to G5 with check King
goes here Queen to F6 with checking goes
here and now a nice night the G5 and
there's no defense Bishop captures and
H7 is coming if you make some room for
the king and f8 uh still doesn't matter
just captures here and this will now be
Checkmate so after Bishop to C2 it's
really not possible to defend even if
you play F6 even if you play F5
everything just uh uh gets completely
shattered so here at Knight 8 the C4 was
played the saying okay maybe it's not as
powerful but now the full power of the
Greek gift or Greco's gift uh you know
no one knows
it will happen Bishop captures an H7
King captures Knight the G5 check and
now of course if you go back as it
usually is in the Greek gift you just
get checkmated so the King has to come
to G6 and there are some positions where
you are allowed to actually accept the
Greek gift and go with King to G6 this
is just not one of those positions Queen
to C2 with check Pawn to F5 or you go
here or you go somewhere and then you
allow Queen to H7 check it's also
a game over so Pawn to F5 e captures an
F6 check out the song King captures on
F6 and now Knight C to E4 with check
black just not controlling any of the
crucial squares here King to G6 and now
she just uh claims the bishop with
Bishop captures on B4 if you wanted to
go for the Brute Force ending you could
also just play Knight to G3 check and
that's pretty much it black has to block
and now you play Knight captures on E6
uh The Rook is hanging the queen is
hanging there there's no defense here
the bishop captures you just deliver on
another check King F7 Queen captures
with check King G8 now Bishop captures
you are up um uh too much material of
course this is completely winning for
white but anything is playable here and
this is a rapid game so you can't uh
just you know uh waste all the time in
the world to find more she played
characters on B4 which is perfectly uh
fine Rook to F5 now comes spawn to H4
Rook the h8 he does get to activate his
Rook but now Knight to G3 and uh well
it's merely a matter of time Queen to C6
was played now comes Knight captures and
f5e captures and Knight back to F3 now
the queen is coming to the G5 and then
uh again uh you're pretty much choosing
the way you want to go here Queen to B5
was played Bishop to C3 and now uh we
have Knight to D5 adding uh another
attacker to the bishop but now B3 now if
you capture first captures comes with an
attack on the queen so Knight back to B6
and now Bishop to D for keeping the
bishop in the game uh because you really
wanted that the G7 pawn attack you are
gonna play Queen G5 Queen captures on G7
again only one of the possibilities Rook
to C8 was played Queen to D2 and it was
in this position on move 29 that Sally
Salim resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here uh the the
there's no defense against Queen G5
Queen G7 and even if you stop it with
Pawn to F4 then Rook to E5 uh in Rook G5
Rook G7 is coming and if you stop this
with some like Rook to j8 then you get
checkmated with Queen to see to check
King to F7 Knight to G5 check King to f8
and now Bishop the C5 check where black
either has to give up the queen or you
cover up with the Knight but still just
Bishop captures and E7 King to f8 and
now a nice Queen to G6 with checkmate
so that's how it would end but of course
he had enough he didn't want to uh play
this game anymore and of course after
Queen to D2 he resigned and uh it's a
good resignation so you always have to
be careful if you uh if your opponent
has uh you know a bishop on this
diagonal or even the possibility or of
Shifting the bishop to this diagonal
because Knight to A5 just loses the game
on the spot uh it seems like uh there's
uh there's not much to be done here but
there was there was a possibility to
stop it but there are some clues that
you can look out for in order not to
fall for the Greek gift like the pawn on
E5 uh not allowing uh black to have
anything on F6 like a knight defending
dh7 Pawn is one of them the bishop
controlling this diagonal or even having
the ability to be shifted to this
diagonal uh is one thing to look out for
the queen being on D1 having access to
the H5 Square after the bishop is
sacrificed ended the Knight to the G5
check so these are some of the things
that you usually have to I really look
out for in order not to fall for the
Greek gift like the D5 Pawn controlling
that's the bishop Bing and this diagonal
the Knight coming to G5 and the queen
having access to H5 if you watch out for
these things uh chances are you will not
fall victim to to the Greek gift but
even here uh when the bishop was not on
this diagonal uh it was enough to fool a
a very strong Grand Master like Sally
Salim so as you can see no one is safe
from the Greek gift or maybe the Greco's
gift we will we will never know uh sure
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
and a little bit of um uh history if if
we can even call that history I would
like to thank Joyce Roseman Lars thisim
and Thomas film uh maltus and Lauren is
pregnant for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on you wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and if Lauren really is
pregnant pregnant then a huge
congratulations to the to the happy
family see you soon